how many people do you think have used
bitcoin and cryptocurrency so far 150
easily 200 200 okay let's say 200. what
do you think it is at the end of this
decade sorry in 2021 2030 what do you
think the number of just humans around
the world that have used this stuff ends
up being at the end of this decade we're
talking nine years here brother yes oh
i'm going for four billion four billion
yeah that's a pretty good guess yeah i'm
going for four billion that's our target
four billion humans in the emerging
world i don't really care about the west
i'm not even considering them four
billion humans in the emerging world and
we can do it now because all these
remittance partners all these people
that wouldn't talk to us before would
even look at us they're coming to us now
even the banks in africa are coming to
us we met with the banks we met with the
government we met with all of these
people they want to learn they want to
understand it they're coming to us now a
year from now it's going to be more
explosive and then we can actually like
let the money flow freely we can
actually you know take some bitcoin sell
it and then turn it into a cash payout
at a uh we call it pos central or
mom-and-pop gas station in kenya or
nigeria south africa
forget it it'll reach the entire world
at that point four billion people easily
four billion people by the end of the
decade and then when you think about uh
we're let's say 30 penetration in
nigeria today so let's go to one of your
most popular markets
what is it going to take to go from 30
to 90 penetration so okay so that number
being thrown on 30 percent is wrong it's
it's less than one percent less than one
percent that's the one percent explain
why
it seems like it's 30 because there's so
much traffic it's incense but people
just don't understand nigerians right
yeah it's our prolific people they have
immense hustle immense drive immense
ambition and energy right so that one
percent seems like 30.
when it actually does get to 30.
oh my goodness i mean at that point
we'll be like
that'll be like three four years down
the line i think and at that point the
whole world all of africa will be moving
forward all of western africa will be
saturated because nigerians are
everywhere they'll drive this adoption
intensely that's what people have to
understand like
to make that happen though will mean
boots on the ground like these
educational centers where people can
come in meet someone face to face that
has to happen because you're not going
to get people in the emerging world
going to this in mass in a purely
digital format this is their money you
know if you go to someone there and say
hey keep your life savings on your phone
or your computer and you're like come on
man
there's a bit of hand holding here yeah
yeah so you think that it's a very small
percentage one percent or whatever right
now uh three or four years to 30 and
then how do we get to 90s it literally
just boots on the ground and everyone
focused on making this happen to get to
90 percent uh this is difficult because
if you go out into like rural parts of
africa like we built uh our sixth
bitcoin built with bitcoin school in
kaduna state in nigeria uh this is
really like rough territory like you
know is that where the fighting is
happening in like northern nigeria okay
exactly we go the places where there's
the most need the school is safe though
there's a lot of protection the
government of the state is you know very
cooperative but if you go to that place
you'll be like out of 100 people and
like two of them will actually have a
cell phone right so you're talking about
the you know there has to be
you know basic uh utilities like cell
phone access first coming in there so
for us to reach 90
we're gonna have to be at the point
we're actually giving away cell phones
where we have mesh networks set up to
support all this infrastructure so
there's a lot that has to lead in there
because people don't understand how
underdeveloped it is outside of the
cities in those places that's the only
thing holding it back
when you think about what it's going to
take from here
what are the things that you're prepared
right when you start out with a story
like egypt when you talk about zuccotti
park those are you know life-changing
moments for you and experiences what
else do you think has to happen in order
for this to
kind of proliferate across the world
you know for all the
tools that we play with we play with
money we play with technology it's a
spiritual battle
you know i i'd sound might sound corny
to some people but it truly is we're
dealing with money here right and money
has been the first pillar that the bad
guys took control of they are able to
basically cut off
value transition of humanity which means
we can't cooperate and cooperation is
our greatest strength
right so we have to understand the end
of the day this is a spiritual battle
we're in a bull market right now and
nowhere is a spiritual battle tougher
than in a bull market right you look at
all the greed happening you look at
all the pain that's going to be coming
because of what's going on right and
what has to happen is we need the best
minds in this space
to take their eyes off of this whole
gordon gecko-ish kind of
nebula that we're in and focus it again
on the ground in the places that need it
most